big birthday coming up I don't know how
you feel about talking about it but if I
I'm fine with it yeah
what's coming up turning 40 soon you're
turning 40 all right yeah it's young
young punk I consider it young it is
young very young I'm excited about it
because I feel like career-wise it it'll
like nudge me into a different demo and
I'll like get a few different offers now
maybe you think like I'm looking forward
to being offered the role as the
wisecracking young enthusiastic teacher
in the coming-of-age movie that then has
to take a step back from the a story
when he gets too involved in the
protagonists personal life right so you
you see yourself as like not a sexual
threat or so yeah exactly but like I
connect with the kids but then it gets
too real like I'm sorry
Janette but this is a little bit out of
my pay grade yeah I'll see you in the
the finale scene at the end from the
audience yeah where you're applauding
it's showing support okay and what else
I'm excited I'm gonna do an erectile
dysfunction ad are you really yeah but
that one's not because 40 is is that old
it's just something I want to do as an
acting challenge why is that why do you
consider an acting challenge well truth
be told they backed up the money truck
you're gonna get paid a lot of money
cuckoo bucks yeah I was like I gotta do
it plus my Wang is super floppy so it's
a good I was gonna say when I think of
non-functioning Dix I think of you you
just insulted him 15 different ways that
was fantastic yeah you started off with
so many life-affirming things and I kind
of bringing me back down to the meadow
no we're happy for you you're gonna get
these this is a whole new stage in your
career yeah how would you being turning
40 I'm excited you know another cool
thing about turning 40 I'm gonna start
knocking things off my bucket list
oh that's a good idea laughs you found
that what's what's on your bucket list
for example uh well I only have two
things at this point for the first one
is I want to jack off on the roof of a
building like Leonardo DiCaprio and
Basketball Diaries
with a I know what you're all thinking
why haven't you done that already and
the answer is because I'm shy and then
the second thing I which I know you want
me to say because I set it up yeah you
mentioned one of the two what's the
second I want to get swallowed whole by
a sea monster then explode out of one of
its eyeballs and yell Beowulf which Wow
I will confess is a reference to the
movie Beowulf it's a motion capture film
that came out a few years ago that's a
great fan of yeah I think you and two
other people loved that movie
well that other person's very satisfied
with their experience because it's a
treat and a half and I highly recommend
all right yeah now speaking of movies
that people want to see Hotel
Transylvania 3 yes
summer vacation yeah we have a clip here
anything you want do to set this up no I
think it probably just speaks for itself
alright now let's take a look at this
clip Hotel Transylvania 3 summer
vacation yeah
fantastic please told you it was good
please explain to me who yeah why does
he yell his own name the running theme
throughout the movie that is not the
only time he does it when I do something
cool I don't yell Koda
maybe you should I should by the way
it's a good thing they didn't show the
Basketball Diaries clip coming up next
week here's a clip I think this is the
right clip let's try it again you know
actually I was thinking you and Johnny
should spend some time together what do
you call it again a date night come on
Johnny
date night
captivate you three certain vacation in
theaters tomorrow Andy Samberg I love it
when you stop by
[Applause]
you